non-minimalists
chris writes in is procrastination
always a bad thing sometimes i need to
walk away from a project
before returning to it with a fresh
perspective and i totally get this man
yeah i get it too
here's my first pithy answer i have two
for chris and then we can talk about it
ryan
don't let your amateur procrastination
turn pro
boom yeah i think uh uh we we can be
we can procrastinate but then what
happens with me sometimes if i put
something off a little bit
i'm like i've already gone down the
rabbit hole i might as well just say
forget everything i put it off for a day
i'll just put it off for a week
yeah yeah yeah and and then it
perpetuates until like i continue to put
it off and
you feel bad about and you realize that
and once you finally get to it two
three months down the road and it took
you an hour to finish this project
you're like
wait a minute i've been worrying about
this i've had this psychological clutter
for the last three months because i
didn't i wasn't willing to spend an
hour getting this out of the way yeah
and so yeah i think about that the
the second short answer the second
minimal maxim i have for you
chris is a planned respite
isn't procrastination any more
than a than a planned car crash
is an accident and if you plan to crash
into a wall
that's not an accident you did it on
purpose right and if you plan
to take a little break from that's
necessary it's the interval training
that we just talked about right
yeah absolutely my short answer is this
one can differentiate
taking a break from procrastination
by considering the amount of guilt they
feel during
downtime for me like this is key because
there are some times when i need to take
a step back from a project and really
let some things digest let some thoughts
digest
but if i'm actually taking a break i
don't feel guilty about it
right when it becomes part of the
process the break is part of the process
exactly but then there are other times
when i am
finding distractions and as i'm
you know uh following through with these
distractions
i start to feel guilty because i'm like
oh i should have been doing this
i should have been doing that and that
is where those are the the
the signifiers that i look for in myself
to really differentiate between
am i am i actually taking a break or am
i actually
uh uh ignoring this this important task
that i need to
i need to work on and so maybe maybe
ryan that
the distractions are related to
procrastination
and maybe the intentional break is
related to the project itself
related to the creativity uh cal newport
talks about this in in deep work when he
talks about
spending time you know just like taking
a walk and in fact if you look at mason
curry's book where he talks
about daily rituals of creative people
whether it's
david foster wallace or mozart uh and
everyone in between
the the two things that i notice in
almost all of the the people in this
book i think it's 163 case studies of
different creative people mostly writers
but not all of them
i noticed some sort of caffeine
consumption
and i noticed daily walks oh wow and
for most of them i noticed early early
working
as well uh not for all of them though
there's some of them like
hunter s thompson who yeah i guess it
was early his writing
started at midnight it's really early
yeah the first hour of the day